[Musique]
sur des kilomètres des chantiers de
citronniers morts brûlés volontairement
par les criminels en fuite dans ce
village les traces d'intenses combats
des façades criblées des vitres
explosées aucun bâtiment n'a été épargné
par les échanges de tirs pas même cette
école où cette église
plus personne ne vit à limone sitôt
en 2021 ce petit village du michoacan
dans le sud-ouest du mexique était le
terrain d'une guerre de territoire entre
le cartel réalise comme va ramer
rationne écarter l'estonie dos
nous rencontrons ce vieil homme que nous
appellerons airs milo deux jours par
semaine il revient ici s'occuper de ce
qui reste de son jardin par peur des
représailles ce n'est que sous couvert
d'anonymat qu'il accepte de raconter ses
nuits d'angoissé cloîtré avec sa famille
dans cette app entier
ici nous avons tenté de nous protéger
d'éviter d'être touché par une balle
nous sommes restés trois ou quatre nuits
après ça nous avons décidé de partir
c'est une chose terrifiante des
fusillades dans tous les sens
certaines balles ont touché la maison
monstrueux
ce qui m'a vraiment fait peur c'est pour
ma famille
les enfants courent est ici et là c'est
tellement triste
à une trentaine de kilomètres plus au
nord dans le village de la juana
eppolito mort à lui refusé d'abandonner
ses citronniers tout comme ses plus
fidèles employés
tous les jours ils passent dans leur
voiture armé jusqu'aux dents comme si de
rien n'était on s'est habitué à vivre
comme ça de toute façon que pourrait-on
faire de plus même si ce n'est pas ce
que nous voulons nous n'avons pas le
choix cet ancien leader d'un groupe
d'autodéfense avait tenté de repousser
les groupes criminels de son village en
2013 à l'époque ces organisations armées
avait suscité l'espoir d'une paix dans
la région neuf ans plus tard
la plupart d'entre elles ont disparu ou
sont gangrené par le crime organisé
le crime organisé est plus présent que
jamais dans la zone est
toujours accompagnée d'une lourde
escorte cette figure locale est la cible
des cartels malgré les pressions il
refuse d'abandonner son village natal il
y a quelques jours l'un de ses gardes du
corps a été assassiné
samedi matin on nous a annoncé qu'on
l'avait retrouvé mort
enveloppé dans une couverture
avec nos impacts de balles dans le corps
torturé et jeté dans une rivière
je pense que c'est une mise en garde que
m'envoient le crime organisé une
nouvelle fois
état le plus meurtri du mexique avec
plus de 800 homicide volontaire recensés
depuis janvier 2022
le michoacan incarne plus que jamais la
défaite des autorités sur ces images des
véhicules de l'armée doit fuir face aux
criminels qui les prennent en chasse et
les insultes la scène s'est passée le 11
mai dernier dans le village de nueva
italia face à cette explosion de la
violence l'exil devient souvent le seul
choix possible
certains comme célia trouvent refuge
dans la capitale de l'état morelia
je suis arrivé ici il ya trois mois je
suis parti suite à la disparition de mon
mari il a disparu le 22 février 2022
dans la ville de sawai au michoacan
des gens armés sont venus à mon domicile
je ne pouvais pas mettre ma vie en
danger ni celle de mes enfants alors
j'ai décidé de revenir ici dans ma ville
natale
ces liens a trouvé ici le soutien dé
vendre et lina à la tête d'un collectif
d'aidé aux personnes à la recherche d'un
disparu elle aussi a quitté sa ville
d'origine après la disparition de sa
fille en 2012
j'ai commencé à recevoir beaucoup de
menaces on disait qu'ils allaient
m'enlever je me suis rapproché du
service des deux victimes de lazaro
cardenas et du procureur de l'époque il
devait me venir en aide mais ils ont été
piégés on leur a tiré dessus leur
camionnette a été incendiée et l'un
d'eux a été assassiné je devais partir
sauver ma fille enlèvements meurtres
déplacement forcé depuis le début de
l'année plus de 4000 dehli portant
atteinte à la personne ont été recensés
dans le michoacan je pense que derrière
chaque personnes déplacées se cache une
histoire de féminicide
d'homicide de dépossession de biens de
leurs exploitations agricoles par
exemple les gens doivent fuir sans rien
depuis 2010 dans l'état du michoacan
près de quatre cent mille personnes
auraient été contraints de quitter leurs
foyers une crise silencieuse qui nourrit
aussi l'exode vers les états unis
[Musique]